Russian forces withdrew from borrowed
the anchor in April last year
large sections of the Town a half hour
drive from Kiev lion ruins
while fighting continues in the East and
despite there being no end of the war in
sight reconstruction of towns like this
one and the rebuilding of vital
infrastructure far from the front lines
is already underway
most of the work so far is being paid
for with Ukrainian cash reserves but
what's being described as the largest
rebuild in Europe since the second world
war could cost a trillion dollars
as the mammoth reconstruction process
starts and the money starts flooding in
there is still serious concerns about
corruption in a report compiled by the
UN along with the organization
Transparency International they say that
these long entrenched problems include
poor governance the influence of
oligarchs on Parliament low Integrity in
the private sector and a compromised
Judiciary and this means that keeping
this reconstruction process clean is a
huge challenge
while Ukraine's International corruption
rating has improved in recent years it
remains dismal only Russia was worse in
the region according to transparency
International's 2022 corruption index
we need to improve their transparency
where our security risks are mitigated
because of the Russian war this is
number one another we need to continue
doing the reforms the judicial reform we
need to start the reform the audit and
the counting chamber of Ukraine and of
course in the long term we're looking
into anti-monopoly committee changes in
order to avoid any violation of the
competition law
experts say Ukraine has cleaned up its
act in some sectors including Banking
and health care but pressure from Civil
Society organizations and digital
auditing of politicians and Company
assets must be ramped up
it needs time it's a huge system we need
to recruit more than 2 000 judges it's a
huge challenge this is one another one
let's strengthen the capacity of the
anti-corruption institutions they need
more investigators they need more
prosecutors they need more more judges
Ukraine's foreign minister reassured
potential investors at a conference on
reconstruction held in Rome you will
hear how much we're doing
to make our country economically viable
and attractive for trade and investment
but the opportunities are here and now
you don't have to wait for the end of
the war
Ukraine's progress to full EU membership
from its candidacy status granted in
June is dependent on reforms many
focused specifically on corruption
on the right track say Western backers
but big questions remain on just how
cleanly their reconstruction money will
be used
Charles Trafford Al Jazeera Kiev